what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and if
i told you that black widow could still
be
alive even after avengers infinity war
would you believe me better yet would
you believe
marvel studios because that is
essentially what they are kind of
telling us
there was an alternate post-credits
scene for black widow that obviously did
not make the cut but this post-credits
scene points to natasha romanov aka
black widow
possibly still being alive now of course
we'll never see
this post-credits scene unfortunately
because it didn't make it to the final
cut but luckily for
us director kate shortland of the black
widow film recently opened up to variety
and told us what this post-credits scene
was actually going to be
and needless to say if you have not seen
black widow or its post credit scene
and you are trying to avoid spoilers you
should probably click away now but if
you've seen it or you simply don't care
about spoilers and want to know what's
going on we'll be talking about the
credit scene and how black widow could
very well still be alive in the mc right
now and eventually make a return
and of course if you love marvel and
want to stay up to date on all things
relating to the mcu be sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so during the black widow film we
are introduced to yelena bolova who
is the sister of natasha romanov not a
blood related sister but as
dom would say from the fast and the
furious franchise she's family
i don't have friends i got family
but throughout random parts of the movie
they would whistle to each other
one would whistle and the other would
whistle back fast forward to the post
credit scene of the black widow movie we
didn't get a scene of an
actual funeral for natasha but we did
get her sister yelena
visiting her grave she goes to her
tombstone starts to kind of clean things
up around it and then
she whistles that same whistle she did
to her sister throughout the movie and
of course
nobody whistles back although a lot of
us were sitting there waiting for that
whistle back
instead valentina allegra de fontaine
comes out
interrupts the nice moment that she was
having and then lies to her and tells
her that hawkeye killed her
sister that's the post credit scene we
got but a post-credit scene that we
almost got instead would have been of
yelena
visiting the grave whistling and then
getting a
response a whistle back this is what
director kate shortland told variety
they almost put into black widow she
said
we never put it in but we talked about
it
now this is incredible news because if
this post-credits scene would have
actually made it in the movie that would
have heavily implied that natasha
was still alive because who else would
be whistling back it wouldn't be anybody
else it would just be natasha and we all
were waiting for it we thought it was
going to happen
but the fact that this alternate
post-credit scene almost made it into
the movie
means that to marvel black widow can
indeed return
if black widow was 100 dead they
couldn't even talk about this alternate
post-credits scene and since they talked
about it that means
they're open to it and if we think about
the logic of the
mcu during the infinity saga concerning
the infinity stones particularly the
soul stone
natasha could actually be alive now
first and foremost before we talk about
how exactly she's still alive i know
scarlett has said that she's done
but we know how marvel and the actors
can be they say
pretty much whatever they need to say to
keep everybody in the dark
paul rudd says that he's not ant-man and
then he's ant-man they tell us it's not
avengers end game the title of avengers
4 and then of course
it is avengers endgame and the fact of
the matter is
natasha could very well still be alive
and i'll explain how
there's actually a very perfectly
logical explanation to this
that actually makes a lot of sense and
it goes back to the soul stone theory
to retrieve the soul stone you have to
sacrifice a soul
a soul for a soul as red skull explains
but it was never really clarified what
happens when you put it back
if the rule is a soul for a soul and you
put it back
doesn't that mean you are putting a soul
back and should receive one
in return and if so and that is the rule
that would mean that natasha would come
back
but ultimately that part might not
actually matter
because steve rogers went back in time
at the end of avengers in-game and he
returned the stones
right when they were taken and if he did
that correctly
then the souls should never be taken and
a black widow should return in the main
timeline
but the rule of a soul for a soul is the
law that
marvel established and again it works
both ways if you give the soul stone
back you should receive a soul in return
and since black widow soul was the one
given up that's the one that should come
back
if we tie this logic into the fact that
we almost got a post-credit scene that
heavily hints at black widow still being
alive this could very well explain
how that could be now ultimately we
didn't get the post-credit scene where
natasha would be whistling back
and that's because marvel has a lot of
stuff going on right now and they needed
this post credit scene to set up the
thunderbolts or the dark avengers we're
unsure at this point in time what this
new team is going to be but they're
going to be a combination of the
thunderbolts and the dark avengers and
they're not
going to be the greatest team they're
going to be a team of
misfits and villains really and you have
to keep in mind that black widow was
actually supposed to be
the very first film or project entirely
for marvel space 4.
unfortunately due to kovid black widow
got pushed back over a year
so other projects came out first and we
got the falcon in the winter soldier
which introduced valentina and
her recruiting us agent john walker for
this team
so we have to think big picture here and
the black widow post-credits scene
was supposed to set up a future mcu
project
it's supposed to tease the future of the
mcu but the big picture
is actually kind of two-fold especially
when it's concerning black widow
one yes the black widow post credit
scene did have to set up this
new team that valentina is recruiting
and again kevin feige has confirmed that
she is indeed recruiting
but two we all just saw what happened
in loki after the loki season finale
anything is possible now
like really anything nothing is off the
table
with the multiverse and infinite
different realities infinite different
timelines
anything can happen which is actually
the really really big picture
avengers secret wars i've been talking
about secret wars before loki came out
i've really been talking about secret
wars even before avengers in game came
out
people were wondering well what's next
after avengers end game how could you
even top that and i stated well
secret wars that's going to be next
that's going to definitely top
avengers end game a storyline in which
multiple different versions of the same
character
come together with other superheroes and
their multiple versions of themselves
or variants as we've learned and then go
on to team up and take on the villains
who of course have multiple different
variants of them fighting together as
well
this is going to be absolutely insane we
already saw
how insane loki got then of course
spider-man no way home is going to be
insane but the big thing
is again nothing's off the table black
widow could easily return
not only could she be alive in our
timeline we could see other versions of
herself coming
thanks to the multiverse and yes
scarlett johansson says she's done but
then you get a movie as big as secret
wars that everybody is going to talk
about for
years and years and years well that's
kind of enough to bring somebody back
you'll want to be a part of that so
black widow could really return
in two different ways one based off of
everything that i've said in this video
she really could still be alive the
logic of the soul stone a soul for
soul rule makes sense since we returned
the soul stone
the soul should be returned therefore
black widow should be alive but if this
is not the case which kind of seems like
it is thanks to the whole
alternate post-credit scene that almost
existed but if it's not the case
black widow could always return in
secret wars she could always return in
multiverse of madness
really at any point because the
multiverse exists now it's a very real
thing
but would you want her to return would
you like her to still be alive in our
timeline or would you like to see an
alternate version of her
in some type of multiverse film
regardless let me know what you think
about this theory
in the comments down below do you think
black widow could be alive
let me know and don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof